Why Does Coffee Make You Poop
As any barista beginning their 5am shift will
tell you, a morning cup of coffee is essential
for a chipper attitude and a healthy psyche!
The dilemma some have is that right after
you indulge- it hits you.
The #2 train is about to arrive and you don’t
want to be stuck in traffic when it does!
In fact, coffee’s effect on the colon is
on par with eating around a 1000 calorie meal.
It’s also interesting to note that the reaction
is not volume or temperature dependent.
Women are more susceptible to these effects
than men (53% for women and 19% for men).
And of those affected, 58% reported the reaction
would only occur if they had not already evacuated
their bowels, and 52% state the reaction only
occurs in the morning.
So what’s going on here?
A commonly touted theory is that the caffeine
inside of coffee is the culprit.
After all, caffeine’s effects on your gastrointestinal
tract have been known for quite some time.
More specifically, one theory about the exact
mechanisms that may be causing this concerns
how caffeine stimulates your central nervous
system- stimulating your sympathetic nervous
system (your fight or flight nervous system)
with the net result being the constriction
of your blood vessels.
Normally responsive to low oxygen levels,
a grouping of cells called chemoreceptors
can get stimulated by this constriction.
Indirectly, this will have a response affecting
your Vagus nerve.
The Vagus nerve can stimulate part of your
parasympathetic nervous system (your rest-and-digest
nervous system) which increases the rhythmic
contractions within the colon.
Thus, taking in caffeine may result in an
increase in your gastric motility, known as
peristalsis.
(In layman’s terms, essentially a wavelike
contracting and relaxing of the muscles forcing
the contents of your digestive system to move
their way through towards your backside.)
However, the “caffeine causes you to poop
after drinking coffee” idea has since been
debunked for several reasons.
To begin with, caffeine will usually begin
its stirring effects about 15 minutes after
ingestion.
Those effects will continue for several hours,
with its half-life at around 5-6 hours on
average.
Why is this important here?
One study specifically looked at the colon’s
response to coffee by placing an anal probe
(FOR SCIENCE!!!) in the large intestines of
those who had an increase in peristalsis from
it.
Coffee’s crappy affects were shown to begin
within 4 minutes after ingestion, and the
increase in peristalsis remained for only
approximately 30 minutes.
These time-frames do not support caffeine
being this particular promoter-of-poop.
The caffeine-cause was further debunked when
it was shown that increased peristalsis did
not happen with other caffeinated beverages,
but would happen with decaffeinated coffee.
So if it’s not the caffeine, what in the
coffee is causing the urge to defecate in
some people?
While it hasn’t been definitively proven
yet, the leading theory behind coffee’s
boost in productivity of your waste management
system is a combination of several hormonal
and neural mechanisms, some known and likely
some as yet unknown.
The known include a rise in acid production
within your stomach and the release of the
two hormones, Gastrin and Cholecystokinin,
which have something of a laxative effect.
To begin with, coffee is relatively acidic,
specifically having a pH between 4.5 and 6.
(And for reference in case you’ve forgotten
your high school chemistry, 7 is neutral.)
In fact, there have been over 40 types of
acids found in roasted coffee.
These can be broken down into three groups:
aliphatic, alicyclic carboxylic and phenolic,
and chlorogenic.
Importantly, chlorogenic acid will also promote
increased acid production by your stomach,
elevating the acidic environment.
In healthy people, this acid-bath will aid
in the digestion of proteins and fats.
The stomach responds to the acid production
by moving its contents more quickly into your
small intestine.
Increased acid levels will also trigger the
release of gastrin and cholecystokinin, which
provokes the aforementioned peristalsis.
Gastrin is produced when the body senses the
presence of food in the stomach, or your Vagus
nerve gets stimulated by one of your senses,
like taste or smell, in response to food.
Its release causes several reactions within
the body.
The gastroesophageal sphincter will constrict,
keeping the food in your stomach, not allowing
it back up into your esophagus.
It increases the motility of your digestive
tract and gall bladder, in preparation for
foods arrival into the small intestine.
Simultaneously, it will relax the valve between
your small intestine and colon, called your
ileocecal valve.
This will allow the food already in your small
intestine to move-on to the large intestine.
Finally, it increases peristalsis throughout
the entire digestive system.
The overall result of gastrin is essentially-
out with the old, in with the new!
Cholecystokinin, while similar in structure
to gastrin, functions differently, causing
other reactions.
It’s also released in response to food being
introduced to the stomach.
It stimulates your gall bladder to release
bile into the intestines, which helps digest
fats.
This could be why people who have painful
gallstones often choose to avoid coffee.
It also stimulates pancreatic juices, helping
to break down large food particles into molecules
that can be absorbed by the body.
Cholecystokinin has also been shown to stimulate
your hypothalamus, signaling the body that
it’s had enough food.
It’s thought this is one of the mechanisms
giving coffee its appetite suppression effect.
All this said, just because these are probably
the main influences on your coffee induced
BM, it is still thought that there are probably
other things going on as well.
This is because there are over a thousand
chemical compounds found within coffee, and
many can affect the gastrointestinal system.
The digestive tract is also extremely complex
and still not fully understood.
For instance, the morphine-like compounds
found in coffee called exorphins attach to
opiate receptors located throughout your body.
There are four known types of these- delta,
kappa, mu, and the very boringly-named, Opiod-receptor-like-1
(ORL1).
All of these receptors are known to affect
peristalsis in some way.
However, it should be noted that most tend
to have the opposite effect as coffee- they
usually cause constipation.
So why is this being considered as a contributor?
The debate arises because there are so many
different reactions that can take place, depending
on which specific type of opioid receptor
gets stimulated.
It also matters at what point in the signaling
process of neurons you stimulate the receptor.
As one researcher put it, “The GI motor
effects of opioids are complex because, depending
on whether interruption of excitatory or inhibitory
neural pathways prevails, muscle relaxation
or spasm will be observed.”
When you combine the complex nature of opioids
with the fact there haven’t been many studies
specifically identifying the regulatory properties
of ORL1, you begin to understand the obstacles
facing researchers.
For instance, it’s known that ORL1 reacts
more quickly than the other opioid receptors,
seeing results after only 2 minutes of exposure
to an agonist.
This makes it a tempting receptor to look
at given the time-frames associated with your
distal colon’s reaction to coffee.
In the end (pun intended), given the extremely
complex nature of the human digestive system
and the multitude of compounds found in coffee,
it will take a significant amount of additional
research to nail down all the contributing
factors in coffee making some people defecate.
But as I finish my morning cup of Joe, I would
like to thank all those brave individuals
to date who have voluntarily had an anal probe
inserted FOR SCIENCE!!! to give us an idea
of some of the mechanisms involved here, as
well as safely rule out others we previously
hypothesized might be contributors.